hey youtubers it's Charlie and yesterday
in my episode 10 review I asked you to
submit all of your Walking Dead
questions generally speaking most people
wanted to talk about Lizzie because we
saw some things that answered a lot of
questions we had from the first half of
the season and some specific events that
were kind of wrapped up quick shout out
to this week's giveaway winner
congratulations - fair - Thompson you
win a $20 Amazon gift card I'll be
reaching out to you on your channel for
details don't worry if you haven't won
anything yet I'll be doing this every
week for Walking Dead
and whenever Game of Thrones comes back
I'll be doing a weekly giveaway for that
- eventually I'll probably even start
giving away t-shirts - just like grace
Helbig so careful for spoilers and the
questions if you haven't seen the
episode yet but let's get started
question number one Jesse Wade asks did
you think that Lizzie would have either
by accident or on purpose suffocated
baby Judith while trying to keep her
quiet in the woods I definitely thought
that she was trying to smother her you
could see her kind of slowly tuned out
and her just covering Judith's mouth
turned into smothering I think it was
only partially unintentional she didn't
want to kill baby Judith but it's like
when a little kid hits another kid to
get them to stop crying and it only
makes things worse Lizzie just wasn't
processing the fact that by covering to
dismount she would eventually suffocate
and kill her her mind just isn't
connecting those dots you know she's a
little out to lunch right now question
number two Mir asks how long do you
think it will be before Lizzie in
quotations you have the sociopath kills
someone in the group so I don't think
that's going to happen in this season I
do think that she'll kill more walkers
and eventually someone is definitely
going to have to openly address the
issue that she's gone a little crazy
before something really bad happens so I
do think that Lizzie will continue to do
like really you know messed-up stuff
like kill rabbits and small animals and
really only Carol is gonna know what's
really going on at least for a little
while I think eventually she'll start
talking to other people about it
question number three - viho main asks
is Lily really dead you're talking about
the governor's Lily yes she is dead I
think that's what we're meant to take
from Terra's speech she didn't
explicitly state that lily was dead but
she was out of bullets and she got
swarmed ter kind of trailed off whenever
she was mid-sentence so I think she just
watched Lily get eaten and that's really
when Glenn found her in the aftermath of
that when she was just in shock just
sitting there by herself question number
four Jonah Armitage asks what is
terminus is that supposed to be a
Andrea so there are actually two
distinct places that the groups go in
the comic books when is the Alexandria
safe zone and the other is sanctuary the
episode was a little confusing because
the word sanctuary kept getting used but
in the comic books they go to Alexandria
first I think the Alexandria storyline
started around issue 69 in the sanctuary
storyline didn't start till around issue
104 so considering that I do think the
terminus was meant to tease the
sanctuary and they'll just split the
groups and one group will go to
Alexandria and the other will head for
sanctuary question number five commander
Sloane asks what would have happened if
Abraham and his group showed up before
the governor attacked the prison I don't
think it would have changed anything I
think it'd have just gotten bloodier
Abraham only has two people with him
including Eugene and Rosita and it would
have taken a small army to keep the
governor from attacking with that tank
so even if they had shown up it wouldn't
have prevented the governor from
attacking question number six David may
I ask Carole Tyreese and the girls went
one way and Daryl and Beth went the
other way you're talking about the train
tracks yes one group went one way and
the other group headed towards the
sanctuary Carol's group was the one that
hitted towards the sanctuary we're not
really sure where Daryl and Beth went
they're just following the train tracks
at this point question number seven
shish-kebab asks why didn't they have an
emergency meeting place you're talking
about the prison group I think because
the first half of the season was kind of
meant established that they were trying
to settle down they'd stop being
soldiers so there was less a sense of
urgency about where to go next
I think they were expecting to stay at
the prison for forever just because it
was so fortified so really the short
answer is is they didn't have an escape
plan because they didn't think they
needed one question number eight Jon
Redgrave asks what are you most afraid
of for this season that you don't want
to happen I would say the hunters
getting their hands on Carl because that
does not go well I won't say what goes
down but you can check out the comics if
you want to know because it is not
pleasant and the hunters in general are
just a really awful Bunch they're really
almost worse than the walkers but if you
want to know all about them just read
the comic books question number nine six
or asks why did Maggie laugh at the end
on the bus she was still a little bit in
crazy mode but she was actually laughing
in relief she was relieved and happy she
had been looking for Glenn she thought
he was on the bus so that's why she was
laughing like a maniac Meghan can go
pretty crazy but up to the point where
she killed that last Walker she
did think that it was Glenn so that's
why she was so strung out question
number 10 careful for comic book
explorers in this one I tried to be as
vague as possible but it's a really good
question so I wanted to answer it cloned
bloodstone asks do you think the big
thing Lizzie ends up doing will happen
and then will the part with Karl go down
like it does in the comic books so given
that the show has changed a lot
especially what happened to baby Judith
I don't think it will go down the way it
does in the comic books just because
they're kind of a pair they'll change
Lizzie and mica storyline a little bit I
think if they did exactly what they do
in the comic books then the audience
would openly revolt most of the people
that watch the show do not read the
comic books so they haven't really seen
how bad things can get that being said I
still think that Lizzie will still do
something totally effed up but they will
tone it down just a little bit okay so
bonus question and last one legend of
the untitled asks you have an amazing
avatar is it possible that Lizzie is the
one who killed Karen and David so after
seeing the rabbits in the episode we can
connect a few dots especially kind of
going in Reverse when we see her
mutilate those rabbits in the episode
and that almost smother baby Judith we
can connect her to those mutilated rats
in the prison so yes I definitely think
that she killed Karen David and Carol is
just covering for her I think that Carol
will explain to someone else eventually
what happened but only after Lizzie does
something really really bad the big
question is is what is Lizzie going to
do that's gonna be really really awful
this season aside from just massacring
Walker just I do think that she's gonna
be killing a lot of walkers in the
season we should totally keep track of
the Karl vs. Lizzie body count because
Karl has started taking out walkers but
now Lizzie has to but thank you guys for
submitting your questions this was a lot
of fun as always and congratulations to
fair to everyone be sure and give her a
high five for winning this week's
giveaway don't worry the next round of
the giveaway starts on Sunday in my
episode 11 video right now you can click
here for my episode 10 review and you
can click here for all my Game of
Thrones Season 4 breakdowns thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives
you